let's something up
oh you know what
hold on a sec
hello Brainiac
is it happening now
great you will have Luther ASAP
blue they're all you have to do is come
and get him
what the hell was that flash is alive
and he has Luther one damn thing at a
time
that artillery is going to wreak havoc
on our front line if there's a
snowball's chance in hell you can
destroy it I expect you to no matter the
cost are we clear
yeah
where the snowball
time to light them all up
for my way
all my big guys let's dance
oh
that's gonna leave a mark
yeah focus on fire on this tank why do
we never get reinforcements
watch your mate
love explosions
foreign
just call me the Pinball Wizard
[Music]
foreign
taking down the flash thing go
she's still in play let me get out of my
way I have work to do
well hey there sleepyhead we've got an
interrogation to get back to
[Music]
walk away
until these guys everything you know
you think they can stop us
pathetic pathetic
at least I'm not a big hero turn stooge
for a space man
okay boomerang
you want to see what a real hero can do
I'll show you
foreign
how do I stop this
tell me how
you have to kill us Diana
we have to die
to save the world
foreign